judd how are you i'm happy to be here
happy to
i wish i was at largo though i know you
know we should uh
mention to people i'm at the largo
theater but i think the last
live gig i did was with you
that's right and sandler and a bunch of
other people
we are an idol that's right
eric idle bo burnham that was a crazy
show it was a great show
you hosted it and it was here at the
largo
i think we have a photograph of you and
i
on stage and also backstage all of us
and i swear to god i think kovid shut
things down
days later and this place is now
empty except for my skeleton crew
this is my last memory of a live
performance was here and that was a
great night
that was a weirdly magical evening
i mean it was almost so great that uh
it was you know it was a good last one
you know it's like if there was going to
be a lesson because what if the last one
you just bombed terribly right front of
the crowd and that you had to sit with
that for a year
yeah not that that's ever happened but
had i bombed that night i would have
felt like oh my god
um i'm through i'm through in the
business and and being here at largo
would have been a terrible
experience for me but i had a very i had
a fun night we all had a fun night
and that's what i think about every day
i come in here is we got to get back to
that place where we can
we can come back here all of us do a
show
and get each other very sick exactly i
you know i love logo i do
you know a benefit there once a month
for the last
four years and i have so many amazing uh
memories of
being there one of my worst memories now
that you mention it
is you know before show you get nervous
so you use the largo
toilet yeah it's kind of right in the
center of things it's a very small
backstage it's right uh right back there
yeah yeah so i was there kind of early
use the restroom for a you know pre-show
deal with its situation and then dealt
with it in an ugly way
and then as i walked out the door
jackson brown was
heading in one of those situations where
you want to go
jackson you want to pull a jim carrey do
not
go in there poor jackson brandon you
know what he hasn't been seen since
he hasn't been seen i think he died
after
after he used that restroom he brought
me so much joy
all throughout my whole life and that's
what i did to him
he was humming doctor my eyes have seen
the ears walked right in
and then was gone he's just dead
you